hey welcome to henry we begin tonight
with a fox news alert big breaking news
on multiple fronts tonight democrats
they are in as much disarray as ever
including another batch of really bad
polls for the imploding joe biden
and we'll sit down with fox nation host
our friend piers morgan we're going to
ask about him walking off good morning
britain last year we'll get more
reaction to his recent interview with
the 45th president donald trump there's
been a lot of drama in pure's life
lately here's a small sample take a look
excuse me the most explosive interview
of the year i don't think you're real
let's finish up the interview morgan
versus the camera
okay so the royal family is accused of
sorry
all right but first tonight billionaire
ceo innovator elon musk has now struck a
44 billion dollar deal to acquire
twitter and he's going to take it
private signaling a return hopefully to
free speech principles to the social
media platform including a whole host of
reforms to make twitter more transparent
more accountable more committed to
freedom of expression now musk said
today in a statement quote free speech
is the bedrock of a functioning
democracy and twitter is the digital
town square where matters vital to the
future of humanity are debated i also
want to make twitter better than ever by
enhancing the product with more features
new features making the algorithms
open source to increase trust defeating
the spam bots and authenticating all
humans now twitter has tremendous
potential i look forward to working with
the company and the community of users
to unlock it now i've been saying this
for years people should be free to say
what they want to say and for you to
discuss a wide range of topics and
political views without just being shut
down silenced and canceled just because
it doesn't fit what their far left
narrative and this by the way goes for
all the big tech that's facebook that's
google that's twitter pretty much all of
them they have all allowed their
companies to morph into one big
left-wing echo chamber and one big arm
of the democratic radical socialist
party so musk's decision to acquire
twitter should be welcome news to pretty
much everyone other than the far left
voices who appear hell-bent on
censorship and canceling uh to help do
the bidding of the democrats and protect
joe biden at all costs the meltdown by
the way is already underway didn't take
long far left columnist jennifer rubin
tweeted quote musk is the answer to the
jeopardy question
what is the one way to make twitter
worse
activist sean king took it a step
further tweeting quote at its root elon
musk wanting to purchase twitter is not
about left versus right it's about
white power okay and the rest of the
media mob well they're terrified of musk
embracing something called freedom of
speech i thought we cherish that take a
look
to me when the the richest guy in the
world takes over the most important
social media platform that's just not a
winning formula to me it reminds me of
old bond movies where you know dr evil
and guys like that or goldfinger were
going to take over the media
i just my tummy meter says there's
something just not great about this
how will this change our lives and when
he says open it up to free speech does
that allow more misinformation on the
platform if you get invited to something
where there are no rules where there is
total freedom forever everybody do you
actually want to go to that party or are
you gonna decide to stay home but you
know this is a weird guy
um and it's gonna be a private company
i'm confused about what to do um you
know we all use twitter
do i stop or do i wait and see what
happens now remember it was the mob that
teamed up with twitter to censor the
hunter biden laptop story and they
falsely called the russian
disinformation they all just russian
disinformation russian disinformation
russian disinformation all in the run up
to the 2020 election all in an effort to
fuel yet another hoax to protect
democrats and as always attack donald
trump but of course the laptop guess
what it was authentic all along and it
revealed damning evidence of how the
biden family foreign syndicate use their
political status to enrich themselves as
a family and to ink lucrative deals with
foreign adversaries you know like in
russia and china ukraine and other
countries around the world and get this
we are learning even more about biden's
lies that he never met with or talked to
hunter about any foreign family business
dealings because according to visitor
logs from the obama biden white house
reviewed by the new york post hunter
biden's closest business partner eric
sherwin guess what he made at least 19
visits to the white house and other
official locations between 2009 and
2015. so tonight the country ought to be
asking
and i'll ask it what did joe biden know
and when did he know it does he still
stand by the lie that he never talked to
his son hunter about his foreign
business dealings and that's not all
according to catherine herridge our
former colleague now at cbs news
prosecutors have subpoenaed paternity
records including tax documents from the
2019
lawsuit that was filed by london roberts
an arkansas woman who had a child with
hunter and according to a 2018 email to
his brother's widow hunter pressured
hayley biden into getting an hiv test
with the email entitled quote you need
to get tested for hiv hallie
okay if you recall hunter was reportedly
having an affair with hallie about a
year after his brother died and before
the relationship apparently deteriorated
but don't forget the laptop story isn't
just a story about hunter biden and his
destructive behavior that story is more
about joe biden and the biden family and
about the media mob and about big tech
in this country and how they colluded to
cover up any and all evidence of the
biden's family and then nefarious
foreign dealings and joe's lies about
not knowing anything about it it was the
biggest election cover-up in modern
political history now had the media done
their job had they actually vetted the
laptop had they actually made the right
decision not a year and a half later but
when it mattered before the election
could that have had an impact on the
election we'll let you make that
decision i think it could have and it's
why so many on the left are so hell-bent
on censoring conservatives and censoring
stories that are bad for democrats and
that's why
they are in complete panic mode over
elon musk's and his commitment to
freedom of speech i thought liberals
believed in freedom of speech i thought
they'd love a guy like elon musk here's
a guy making electric cars they dream of
electric cars they go to sleep at night
dreaming of electric cars hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else